[Laughter]
wake up one ear posit oh yeah yeah both
them in from what yes called - dude it's
crazy I'm Brennan doesn't know that many
numbers come one we got lunch lady
gloves on freaking disease you it was
upcoming tasks on at each one and y'all
gonna die but I don't think so dude
funeral taking your wallet and you head
into the ground
gonna stop anything don't ever touch me
bro oh then it's a good idea to stop
biting my nails
wrinkly shirt used to be a shirt now
this is a mask yes so creative whatever
yeah man you guys don't know [ __ ] man
what do you guys been doing living
living not getting Corona you look like
you're trying to keep Corona end dude
what am I
you look like Larry Corona do you think
I started it somewhere outside of New
Jersey like Boy George's mean aside
piece sloppy joe gloves I've ever seen
and you look like you just saw penguins
on the dark web profile nice you look
like frickin Larry Corona stalking shady
dude you look like you'd be on real
thought husbands of Corona
County dude you don't like the worst
scarecrow right now there's only trying
to scare girls away oh yeah but
welcoming the gay guys no guys I allow
them I get that painted on this side of
it even up dude dude I'm chillin alive
man taking care of myself huh take it
I'll tell that I'm in here yeah you're
good thank you good you good
we're like a scarf well I don't want to
just cover up mine too cool Jersey I'd
have yeah shut up the Houston cheating
actresses oh the fans didn't know doll
get to our rep son yeah I run the city
so yeah the worst thing is it's hard to
use your phone with these Corona mitts
on those are corona myths those are
protective keeps thinking they do the
job you want to extra scoop of breakfast
I got it you want an extra scoop of iris
don't have it so it see how safe I am
dude you get tested
no a friend of mine got tested that when
they're fine so you good
I'm not good but it definitely takes the
edge off a little bit you know yeah if a
close buddy got it tested you know not a
buddy who had it
I love up Vernon's like hey mate what do
you cuz you're [ __ ] Patrick Swayze
wig was blocking the other one figured
it's like hey why do you have two ones
what do you have what do you have what
do you got that your mom right now is
like what do you have one of your pot
and then one ear pod in I'm like to
Britain okay it's the big adventure
after the number one you tell a joke and
I hear extremis later
telephony aware to assume oh you guys
are disgusting man not to you guys but
somebody all
[Music]